[inaudible]
like a boss.
I came across this group called the shadows and they got a song called FBI and
you just have to see the synchronized dancing,
the choreography that they're doing.
Um,
[inaudible]
you know,
you guys can keep sending me the bad covers,
but a whole nother level of funny is some of the bad choreography because
nowadays when you look at the choreography that people do,
it's like a,
I mean,
th the,
the dancers nowadays are so good,
they'll have 20 people on stage and you're watching them and they're all moving.
They're doing the exact same move at the exact same time.
[inaudible] [inaudible] hum.
And back then in the 60s,
it was basically,
as long as you were doing the same movement within three seconds of the person
to either side of you,
it was considered,
uh,
if it's considered,
I guess decent.
So check out a search shadows,
FBI.
This is some of the worst choreography I've seen.
And uh,
if you want some bad heavy metal,
this is a whole nother genre.
And I haven't even tip even even like tapped the surface of this.
Uh,
look up Britny Fox and Brittany's B R I t e n y Fox girls' school live.
And just watch the first 10 seconds of their stupid swishing back and forth that
I thought was fucking cool as hell are here is Brittany Pot.
[inaudible]
I literally saw it and I was like,
oh my God,
this is,
uh,
I was like,
oh my God.
No.
I was like,
I literally said,
Oh my God.
I know a fucking ditzy girls have ruined saying,
oh my God.
But it used to exist,
you know,
like when you saw Zeplin fucking burning back to the goddamn earth with people
on fire jumping out of it.
Yeah.
And you're about to see the pictures he got when the ship exploded.
Those aboard leaping polite from a flaming inferno.
The actual pressure of the Hindenburg,
an airship destroyed in less than half a minute.
[inaudible]
oh,
that was all the humanity.
Um,
and then the last one isn't even synchronized dancing,
but this is the main reason why it took me so long.
And I never really got into Dave Matthews was that stupid dance,
that White Guy,
James Brown fucking dance that Dave Matthews used to do.
Just search Dave Matthews dance and it's,
it's,
you know,
you really just want John Belushi to come back from the dead and do that animal
house scene where he smashes the guy's guitar.
Except you really want them just hit Dave right over his fucking head.
No.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] sorry.
And the only reason why I ever got in to listening to Dave Matthews was,
uh,
their drummer.
And then I really liked it was a saxophone solo that I just thought was the shit
on one of their earlier,
uh,
earlier ones.
Other than that,
I just,
I,
I don't know,
I just haven't been into them.
So you know,
if you,
you know,
now,
right there,
that's a lot of work.
That's a lot of shit to go look up.
What,
you know,
what,
why don't you take the express checkout line?
Okay.
The automated checkout line and just go to the [inaudible] podcast.com we'll
have all those fucking videos right up there.
You can watch them.
We'll have them in order the highway to hell,
right?
The Dave Matthews,
I mean,
very little times in life,
do what would I ever be on the side of a bully?
But I swear to God,
if right in the middle of his dance,
if the stereotypical high school football player walked up to him with his
jersey,
still on with two of his other meathead friends,
and they just stuffed him into some locker that they brought on stage and
smashed his guitar,
you could hear me laughing from the back of the fucking stadium that they were
playing.
I would completely enjoy it.
And I don't know what that says about me.
[inaudible].